das monster war und hier sind wie gesagt
es sind 1000 kalorien und ich immer als
den ersten bissen jetzt gerade ihm
gesehen leute die vorbestellung phase
für meinen merge wird am ersten zwölf
beginnen das ganze wird nur für eine
woche verfügbar sein heißt vorbestellung
werden nur eine woche dann möglich sein
am 8.12 schluss für alles dann wären die
bestellung gesammelt ausgesendet das
heißt wer davon was haben wollt müsst
ihr auf jeden fall zwischen dem ersten
und dem 812 bestellen wenn ihr mehr
infos dazu volt folgt auf jeden fall es
kay supply auf ihn zukam erster nicht in
der beschreibung der weil wir mit allen
informationen versorgten jetzt viel spaß
mit dem video kindertag in hamburg gebe
was einkaufen
herzliche konnten wir kommt mit der
feierlichen rede hier kaufen was sein
und machen heute fest banken
es war ein kilo schokolade vor der
einfahrt stecken
unser hamburger einkauf hier für mich
wie ein kleines kind als ein kilo
schokolade ich will einfach so ein
richtig fettes teil machen aber jetzt
kann die kamera hat meine realen kilo
bist du verrückt das vierte fehlt wenn's
aussehende gerne lässt sich genug wartet
dann kaufe ich mir noch ein halbes kind
ok leute jetzt meine bude von
weltmeister 3000 mediation
wir sind hier am start mit dem verstand
gesehen ist gewesen ging's lang gefahren
das ding ist er seine 250 gramm die
woche 180 leute im allgemein zu erkennen
was wir machen als allererstes vermengen
wir butter zucker und sahne und dann
später kokosraspeln um diese weiße
mischung in dem board zu machen okay
zusätzlich zur butter sechs esslöffeln
ein teil aus dem alter schwede hatte so
spahr gesehen einfach butter mit zucker
zusammen habe ich noch nie getan jetzt
die sahne dazu bis der zucker dann
fertig ist also komplett rühren
walter war richtig bock akkus an einfach
besser zu beraten oder vorbei jetzt nach
zugang der saane sieht das ganze dinge
so aus wir machen jetzt quasi die
vorstufe machen die befüllung hin
trainieren und dann kommen wir zurück
ist eine sache gekühlt und dann kommt
die schokolade ausbauen und ich bin halt
am end ist hier sage ich euch auch wie
viele kalorien dieses ding hat ihr
werdet es nicht glauben
pfeiffer glaubt mir also leute
beschäftigten zucker an dann kommt das
jahr 1600 gramm kokosraspeln jetzt leute
die gerne
ich war damals nicht mehr rein
diesen cleanskin legt man eine platte
darauf dass alufolie so nehmt das hier
und dann nehmt ihr einfach feuer crack
aus dem popsong war das einfach euer
crack junge was für einen wert letztlich
gar dass so viele junge ist sogar älter
weiß worüber ich kann mich gar nicht
zusammenreißen das kind in mir bilder
rein springen wir uns ja dass wir einen
bauträger nachher mehrere laden kokos
machen also wir machen quasi die
schokolade cocos noch mal schokolade
noch mal kurz noch mal schokolade also
ein big band der geschichte quasi darf
man auf jeden fall war es okay ich habe
jetzt richtig ist dass wir das unterfeld
wir müssen das heißt mega schwer
das ist schwer aber geil
ok bisschen shoppen floss zum browsen
wars noch frauen kann
leute wie lassen die ganze macht jetzt
hier draußen balkon bei ungefähr 0 3 1
zoll stündchen abkühlen gehen der ball
trainieren
so leute training ist fertig jetzt 100
mal 100 gutes zeug um bei kuren sexy
aber sogar was ein was machen wir jetzt
wir bauen uns jetzt sofort
dann fahren wir dann schließlich gerade
ein kilo schokolade leute heute guck mal
ich hab mich schon geklappt hat ich habe
gedacht der schokolade und habe einfach
nicht angedacht dass ich noch
schokoladen finger ab und an von polio
ruiniert aber wir sehen jetzt
theoretischer reif für die erste lage
schokolade die erste lage
ihr erster lage schokolade können wir
jetzt auch schon mal die erste lage hoch
aus rein machen
das ist wirklich wie so ein richtig
geiler fester plätzchenteig gleiche form
noch mal aussprechen ist jetzt wirklich
die fliesen eigentlich mit also ein
fliesenlegern oder sich einfach kokos
fliesen reinlegen jetzt dass man das
brötchen hier wieder schwimmen mit der
schokolade ganz wichtig auch immer du
musst immer zwischen dem probieren ob
die schokolade noch schmeckt kann immer
sein dass schokolade auf einmal anders
schmeckt als schokolade deswegen
mindestens alle 15 sekunden überprüfung
bemerkten die zweite lage
schön alles abdecken
roland es seine fünfte sekunden deutlich
überschritten
noch nicht äußern
jetzt hier kommen wir vom schokoladen
welche zurück die fließwege tätigkeit
denn wir müssen wieder eine kokos fliese
draufmachen 10 kleines eckchen jetzt
haben wir noch mal 400 gramm schokolade
wenn man diesen dicken fetten passen wir
haben aber viel zu viel cookies leute
heißt wenn ihr was abhaben wollte von
kupfer dann kommt vorbei in hamburger
straße 30 40 50 jetzt die finale schicht
leute
das ist richtig viel älter
auch techno cup leuten okapi das ist
dennoch bleibt bailly diehl eben dieses
know car life die sondermission hier in
die aus haltungsform mit dem weg was
zwar etwas anders sein welche reifen
nicht weiß nicht so kurz vorm ziel wo
junge das ist es alter ja wo leute und
jetzt nur noch auf über wunder mit
erwarten giggs 1 1 stunden später ganze
ist abgekühlt
erhöhte gefahren gerade hier an den
ecken ist es richtig nicht wir müssen
jetzt operieren patienten muss dringend
gegessen werden hat auch alufolie
das monster bounty das sind wie sah es
in 12.000 kalorien und ich habe jetzt
den ersten wissen wird die wir das
gleiche sein kuchen nur so kuratorin
nina leben gegessen sollte das der
connect sich so wie in diesem sinne
leute wenn euch das video gefallen hat
las gerne live kommentare was ich als
nächstes mal nach backen basteln sollen
an süßigkeiten bis zum nächsten mal 300
sportschau